[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] I
live in turin in a neighborhood
called falchera unfortunately falchera and
very stereotyped as a ghetto suburb
with a higher crime rate than
in other neighborhoods a social degradation
I was born  here in falchera the neighborhood
in the 80s was, let's say, in a
rather critical situation
in the early 2000s things changed a lot
for the people who got busy i
started my voluntary activism activity at
the age of twenty together
with
a  group of guys we created
this youth social table that
started its history in this
place called file club the
fall club space has always been a space
dedicated to youth
and teenagers activities
after the renovation here at the fall
club our idea  is to
then start a project that would also involve the
families of the neighborhood and make them co-
protagonists with the young people who this
type of design  and it involves
people right from the start they are the ones who
then create the real change enjoy your
meal
working with young people with children
allows you to empty your mind being
contaminated by their energy
doing it in the place where you live and being able to
see the consequences no of what
do is something that gives you more motivation
and also seeing how it is
possible to truly participate
in the life of the community
many of the kids with whom we
did the activities then became that
the dance teacher who helps
the organs after-school
plans  activity for young people i
see them a lot 15 years ago i am
very happy because this is a hope for
others future
[Music]